tonight is an emotional night for you
because the song you're nominated for us
with nipsey what does it mean to be here
celebrate his legacy first of all the
marathon continues long live knit just
to be nominated for higher now I
appreciate it and I'm and you know I
told knit one was making the record
we're gonna get we're gonna get some
awards we're gonna get nominated I'm
sayin so you know I'm is grateful for
the for the nomination and grateful to
work with the King knit look who's
behind you right now
Gigi and Bella I I'm sitting right
beside I'm Gia subject talk to me about
being Apple's artist in residence what
does this mean what are you going to be
doing play this I got I got the office
DJ playlist so I pick all my favorite
songs that I like to work in my office
and I my I play this is crazy
no no it's crazy tell me this there's a
lot of heat on the Super Bowl right now
and you're in the middle of it I don't
know if you know this because rihanna is
a rock client and we think it could be
Rihanna
but then there's JLo holding down in
Miami have you heard from either of the
ladies which one you will be
collaborating with on the Super Bowl
this year I'm gonna be on collaborate
I'm gonna let me elaborate songs with
both of the ladies it's kind of between
Rihanna and JLo and I feel like you
would be in the middle and like a floral
shirts Miami you'll come in a yacht in
the middle to the Super Ball if I get
the opportunity I course Rihanna and JLo
pick up all the Queens all the all the
Queens
[Music]